[Música]
concluyó la cumbre de tres días de los
jefes de estado y de gobierno de los
países del g7 las siete mayores
economías del planeta el encuentro
estuvo marcado por supuesto por la
guerra rusa en ucrania y minaya en
dirección a madrid de la apertura de la
cumbre de la otan en su declaración
final los mandatarios se enviaron un
mensaje claro de unión contra rusia y
por eso entonces nosotros queremos
saludar a la doctora a niveles de
contreras a suárez ella es analista de
asuntos globales y coordinadora a la
licenciatura de negocios globales de la
universidad iberoamericana de ciudad de
mexico doctora niveles nuevamente
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de francés de cuatro muy
buen día
al contrario esto saluda
desde la ciudad de sal
parís es muy bonita la ciudad de parís
es doctor a nivel bueno como leer
entonces esta declaración final de los
líderes del g-7
interesante este cuestionamiento porque
es una perspectiva que tenemos estando
del lado de
y otra cosa es la narrativa que se
maneja aquí en europa a pesar de que los
acuerdos son los mismos las percepciones
o decir
en concreto un lado vimos a un baile
donde mandaba un mensaje muy claro y
contundente con respecto al incremento
de las funciones anuncia en cuanto a ya
eliminar cualquier tipo de importación
el foro hizo esto acuerdo de que en ir
unidos marcan un frente común comparte
las siete economías más importantes en
vísperas en esta antesala a la ya
inminente cumbre de notar en cuanto a
cómo se percibe desde europa te puedes
ir en nuestra es ciertamente yobái de
esta imagen fortalecida y si quiere
manejar por parte de la casa blanca a lo
largo y ancho de lo que es el hemisferio
occidental es decir acá en europa lo que
se percibe y las preocupaciones de la
gente que está en cumbre del g7
realmente sólo cuesta abona a la hierba
las percepciones y la guerra actualizada
en ucrania aunque estas cumbres no sirve
pareciera que ya alguien estas compacta
los europeos regulados por la pandemia
por otro lado ahora viven puesto
y estamos en dos entonces está en busca
del presiente que concluye como muchas
otras no sirven para la foto sirve para
mandar un mensaje claro a vladimir putin
de que no están dispuestos a
extender esta guerra pero
lamentablemente dentro de estos acuerdos
[Música]
pues
claro ariel hablando de eso que usted
dijo cómo hacer para que realmente estas
cumbres sirvan de algo en el terreno
porque como recordemos también uno de
estos puntos concluyentes la cumbre del
g7 fue pues ayudar a esta crisis
alimentaria a ayudar a desbloquear todos
estos granos y salidas y cereales
represados en los puertos ucranianos
para poder distribuirlos en el mundo
como realmente hacer para que el
gobierno de vladímir putin despeja estos
puertos y ya pueda circular el comercio
normalmente como lo hacían antes de
iniciar esta guerra porque parece que
putin pues obviamente no va a decir que
va a abrir los puertos para que estos
granos pues sean enviados y que sean
liberados no de los puertos ucranianos
contigo raúl y me parece que lo que se
necesita es sin duda que los oros y los
organismos multilaterales
intervengan esto es todo mucho que al
interior de estas siete economías más
industrializadas están dando batalla en
cuestión de sanciones económicas a la
disputa entre poder resolver la queja de
los didácticos y ahora la gente nombra
no sé de quién consideró intervenir la
fao
el organismo especializado de las
naciones unidas que atiende los asuntos
de altura pero también sin duda hay que
entender el tema de los energéticos
porque acá en europa ya existe cierto
temor y que había está escucharse entre
la gente y en algunos medios locales que
la gente está preocupada por la cuestión
de la posibilidad de que se vaya a
racionalizar el das no solo en los
hogares sino inclusive en muchas
industrias que dependen al 107 por uno
delgado ya la 90 nacional usándolo en
alemania y me parece que hoy existe ya
una servicio y una gran preocupación en
europa porque debe hacerlo desde eeuu
pues entonces a lejos de europa y estos
años cuenta con gas cuenta con petróleo
pero aquí no hay una certeza
abastecimiento ni una garantía de
proveeduría gas de muy importante
ninguno de los dos
energéticos entonces estamos viendo
hoy más que nunca lo que se necesita es
el multilateralismo se requiere la
diplomacia de activamente y el mundo
avance y no nada más como que son temas
de los siguientes efe
hombre del g7 en impacto a nivel macro a
veces descendiendo muchas naciones en
siete consideran únicamente lo que se
resuelve ahí para beneficio de estas
siete naciones no precisamente esto hoy
seguimos agua entonces ahora
ambas son cede a las próximas horas en
la opa claro a nivel también parece que
la táctica digamos que de las sanciones
de las grandes potencias internacionales
finalmente no funcionan de mucho por
ejemplo lo estamos viendo en el acuerdo
nuclear con irán que se salieron
unilateralmente el acuerdo digamos en el
caso del 2018 unilateralmente con
actualización de oración ya se están
volviendo a sentar en la mesa viendo que
las sanciones no servían también lo
vimos en la cumbre de las américas
cuando estados unidos excluyó a varios
países entre ellos venezuela pero vemos
también que ya hay una delegación de
estados unidos en venezuela tratando de
negociar pues algo tan importante como
la energía y el petróleo digamos más
allá de las sanciones porque estos
líderes estas potencias internacionales
no tratan de llamar a rusia a la mesa de
diálogo buscando puntos en común para
poder finalizar realmente esta guerra
porque viendo que evidentemente en el
terreno y con un armamentística digamos
no se está resolviendo sino agravando la
situación más destrucción más muertes
porque no cambian de táctica los líderes
internacionales viendo los fracasos en
el pasado
pareciera entonces la única 100% contigo
pues entonces el mensaje que nos mandan
es que no tiene la intención y la
voluntad un acuerdo de paz lo único que
quiere decir está usando la guerra para
reactivar la economía de guerra y
atender los intereses personales
pareciera que su postura está cada vez
más indicada entonces de ejecución a
miento
cada vez vemos medida únicamente
lo hemos visto ya mayor el cuerpo y la
piedad en la delegación oakland
económica para trabajar en intentar
poner sobre la mesa estas líneas rojas y
avanzar vemos inclusive un día que el
espectador aún está interesado en su
postura de continuar no a su vez de
ingreso del suelo bastante a mano
donde está grande energética pero de los
metales y también de los granos del que
están espuma claro porque mientras ellos
estén por temas resueltos el mundo cada
vez se fue en medio de este gran urbe